[Music]
all right are we ready yes yes all right
testing games in the cloud welcome I am
Justin I'm an engineering manager at
Google and today we're going to talk
about testing mobile games in the cloud
so hopefully all of you have seen the
what we're calling a Dory
which was on the previous slide it's
also there's a link in the session page
for this session in the app and with
that you can ask questions if you
haven't been to a session before you can
actually ask questions during this
presentation you can add questions there
and we will have plenty of time for
questions at the end in fact I'd even
like to open it up to a little bit more
than perhaps questions so maybe it's
understand a little bit more about your
experiences with testing of games but
we'll get there so so let's start by
asking the question when we test apps
and games what are we looking for well
in some respects games are just like
applications so we're looking for
signals that might indicate a problem or
a bad experience such as slow startup
time of course we're also looking for
crashes or not responding events which
give a particularly bad experience to
the user we're also looking for
incorrect behavior where the game does
not behave as we intend or indeed as the
user expects but with games
we care very specifically about a number
of things one of this one of these is
incorrect or slow rendering that is
because games provide an immersive
experience an immersive experience which
is thoroughly ruined if your UI is janky
or slow so what a games company's doing
today around testing well I've talked
with perhaps many of you and certainly a
lot of games companies and there's a
whole hell of a lot of manual testing
going on that is manual testing before
you release and then releasing to a
whole bunch of alpha or beta customers
for a bit of free testing there is some
not a lot there is some test automation
but it's usually homegrown which means
it's specific to the perhaps proprietary
game engine you're using or to the
company that you've built it in so it's
not widely applicable it's not widely
applicable outside of the company in
which you work all that game engine well
you might be asking why is this a
problem well it's a problem mostly
because of expense you can sort of
imagine training all of those testers to
not only play the game but actually to
become good at the game so they can get
to the later level so they can find the
issues that your users are going to find
some months after you've released into
production and then you have to manually
test across a variety of different
devices and then verify the results
which of course is even more expensive
and the testing has to be repeated every
time you want to release to production
the testing and this is probably the key
part the testing is also performed
particularly late in the process which
means you've no idea which of the myriad
of changes your developers have made
that could be possibly causing this
particular problem so catching problems
earlier is just not possible and we all
know the catching problems earlier makes
them easier to fix as well as cheaper
and lastly there is no safety net which
means your games developers or you as a
game developer you don't know if the
change you're about to commit is going
to break the game in some fundamental
way so why are games companies and
developers not flocking to automated
testing well turns out but testing games
is frankly really really hard so
recently I had surgery which is why I'm
sort of limping around on stage here and
I spent a lot of time lying in bed and
did what might some might call research
which involved playing a whole bunch of
games now I don't actually play games
that often but in bed I was able to play
quite a few games I also during the
playing of this these games
hence the research part was thinking a
lot about how to test these games and
how hard it is to test these games so
why is it hard well firstly games are
rendered with something like OpenGL or
one of the newer frameworks like Vulcan
which makes them really hard tests
because none of the existing testing
frameworks that you might use for
testing applications will work like UI
Automator or XE test or
or you espresso so these regional
traditional tools don't work but also
games offer a huge array of possible
inputs you can imagine playing a game
like clash of clans or World of Warcraft
and you're able to move that character
pretty much anywhere on the screen or
build that tower in the corner or in the
middle or whatever so essentially the
number of interactions you can have
where the game is virtually infinite and
games are often deliberately
unpredictable which means that they give
a different experience to the user every
time but that means they give a
different experience the test every time
which makes it very hard to write an
automated test
and lastly issues are harder to reach
often you have to get to some of the
later levels to actually find a
particular issue you can imagine that
your ogre on level 10 your favorite ogre
just suddenly died and even no idea why
now up until quite recently the only
generally available option for testing
mobile applicants was monkey testing and
if anybody has had experience with
monkey testing especially of games
you'll know it's not particularly
helpful rarely does it get very far into
the game to be particularly useful and
also it doesn't exercise the game as a
user would so you may not even care
about the issues it finds it's probably
good at finding crashes or issues at
startup but really not much
so before we get into actually talking
about the solutions the specific
solutions for testing mobile games in
the cloud I need to first introduce our
cloud testing platform which is firebase
test lab this is actually something that
I have been working on at Google for
about five years now
firebase test lab is part of the suite
of application quality products within
the firebase umbrella it allows you to
test your app or game in the cloud
across a variety of different devices
including most importantly some high end
gaming devices on iOS on Android on
physical devices as well as virtual
devices you can test in different
languages and you can test in different
screen orientations and with the
comprehensive test results that you get
you have screenshots and video and then
the most important form its metrics we
talked about earlier such as startup
time and specifically for games frames
per second as well as CPU memory network
and so on importantly these metrics are
synchronized with the video so that you
can tell when your video is displaying
whatever is happening in your game you
can tell what's happening with your
performance metrics and vice versa
so you can tell you get some context
into whatever problem there is also you
get crashes not responding events logs
and and much much more
fire based test lab is also and this is
surprisingly unknown this is far based
Tesla is also the engine behind the play
pre-launch report how many people here
have heard of the play pre-launch report
how many one - Wow - okay but so in case
you don't know which is apparently 99%
of you here what the pre-launch report
is pre pre-launch report is a three
report the we give to developers for
simply uploading your app or game into a
testing track within the Play Store it's
under the release section within the
Play Store of your app when you after
you deploy it it tests your app or game
across about ten devices and gives you
the same comprehensive test results and
did I mention it's free so there's
really no excuse not to at least take a
look at it alright so when I mentioned I
talked with a lot of game developers the
one thing that I heard most often from
them is security we heard this from so
many of you that the security of the
game is your biggest concern much more
so than say application developers that
is because a leak of a pre-production
game would be really really bad and that
is why we've put a lot of effort with a
lot of focus around making sure the the
device on which you're testing is
completely cleaned up both before and
after your test so there's no
possibility of leaking the game or
seeing the results of the game in a
future test in most cases we simply
flash the device between test runs we
also perform a security check on the
submitter of the tests as well as the
game or app itself
and there you go I knew I was gonna
forget all right so how much this cost I
hear you ask
well we charge you $1 an hour for an
Android virtual device and then $5 an
hour for a physical device iOS or
Android but the key here is we only
charge you for as long as your test runs
which means that if your test runs for
say five minutes on the on a pixel -
it'll cost you about 40 cents we don't
charge you for how long it takes to
install your application to pull off the
results from the device
- post-process those results to ship
them off to Google Cloud storage we only
charge you for how long you specify your
test run and that's pretty cheap trust
me so really there's no excuse not to
implement some regimen of automated
testing which brings us to how you might
go about doing that which is what you've
all been patiently waiting for me to
start talking about all right
so firstly and mostly most importantly
you're going to want to prepare your
game for testing in the cloud you may
want to create a special version of your
game or you can build testability
actually into the code in test lab we
set a property that you can test for you
can then bracket the code in your game
by testing by with an if statement that
simply tests this property so there are
many things that you might want to do to
make your game more testable firstly you
could focus on the preamble you could
remove some or all of the preamble so
that the test can get to the gameplay
more easily you could remove sort of the
login part or the registration or
something
as I talked about earlier you probably
want to remove the randomness so that
the tests that you write are less flaky
they see the same board or game or Lori
can interact in the same way every time
you might want to start the game at a
specific level or load a whole bunch of
assets into the game so that the game
looks like it's been played for a long
time that will allow you to more easily
test these later levels or more
sophisticated gameplay and of course
there's a lot of probably a lot more
that you can do the main be specific to
the game so with test lab you can run
lots of different kinds of tests some of
which are specifically targeted at games
one test that requires little well
relief no effort on your part is Robo
anybody familiar with Robo here yes all
right we've got two okay Robo is a
framework of application crawlers that
are used under different conditions
so when Robo sees an app ache screen
such as that rendered by say OpenGL or
Vulcan or whatever it will switch to a
crawler called the monk they enhanced
monkey action crawler this crawler today
uses machine learning to interpret an
opaque screen and identify screen
elements on which it can click now Robo
shows a yellow circle in the video which
you can see behind me whenever it
interacts or clicks with your app the
app or game
and clicking as it turns out on the
let's roll here which it's what it's
robos decide to do is exactly what it
needs to do just get to in the actual
gameplay four Mecca hamster now this is
Mecca hamster make a hamster I'll talk
about a lot later but it's a game that
we built in five days all right
so Marvin if we can switch to the demo
so I'm gonna do a quick demo of how you
might run a test a robo test within five
days within five days test lab so this
is the fire based console how many
people use firebase here a few oh that's
much better
all right thank you alright so you've
probably been down the left nav bar here
under the quality section you'll find
test labs so we're gonna click on test
lab here and we're going to run a test
so I'm going to pick from this I'm gonna
say I want to run a robo test so I'll
pick a robo test I'm going to browse for
my OOP what happened there that's
interesting yeah resize that for a
second if that's the worst thing that
happens too many demos today I'll be
happy alright anyway so I'm gonna click
on this here which is the mecha hamster
apk to upload there we go that's better
alright so now this is the mecha hamster
game it's going to upload this game into
a storage cloud storage bucket rather
slowly I might add
alright it's gonna upload it into a
google cloud storage bucket and then
it's gonna allow us eventually to pick
from a set of devices on which we want
to run this test so what will you'll be
presented with and I don't think we'll
ever get there but what we will be
presented with is a list of devices
about a hundred or so of different API
levels that you can choose from now of
course we have virtual devices and
physical devices for the most part what
we understand from games developers is
you only really care about physical
devices so you can pick from the set of
Android physical devices and of course
we have lots of pixels lots of Samsung's
lots of lots of different devices that
you can choose from high-end low-end
gaming devices and so on and I don't
think it's ever gonna get this so then
you pick your look Karl you pick your
screen orientation and so since it's
never gonna get there I'm gonna select
here and go to the other thing I ran two
days ago from where somewhere somewhere
where they had a little bit more Wi-Fi
and these are the test results from that
run it's a robo test across three
different devices API is level 26 27 and
28 on a pixel too so very quickly we can
take a look at the test results now you
have full access the test results is
even a way to get to the raw test
results which are just files in a cloud
storage bucket but we got here sort of
various statistics about the crawl we
have logs we have screenshots here it's
a unity game so there's the and we'll
eventually get the screenshots and of
course we have the video and the
performance metrics here and you can see
here the video which I'll actually start
playing here the video it probably won't
come through but you can see that we
have all the different metrics
associated with the video and as the
video plays which it probably will never
do there'll be a little gray line that
comes across the screen to tell you
where you are within all of the
performance metrics so this is very very
important then frames per second here
shows you the the graphics here shows
you there's a there's a dip here at the
beginning you may be concerned about
that but anyway you get the context for
for there's the results
all right let's let's switch back to the
slides please
all right with a little bit more efforts
you can actually record test scripts so
last year at the games development
conference in San Francisco we announced
a partnership with net East Nettie's is
one of the largest games development
companies in China they had previously
built an integrated development
environment called air test which they
used internally for testing their own
games so they at the game tsubame
conference they released that
development environment to the world
they also open sourced a couple of
different testing frameworks that they
use for testing their own games the
first is called air tests like the IDE
and involves image recognition so you
can simply select an image that you
wanted to recognize and then interact
with that particular screen element the
second and probably more importantly is
called poco poco is actually built into
the game engines so there is so it
actually publishes a hierarchy of screen
elements which allows you to interact
directly with the screen elements from
within the IDE and from within your test
scripts so poco has support for unity
and Koko's and also the android
framework itself so you can record
scripts with the game running locally
I'll show that in a second you can then
package those scripts into an
instrumentation test that youth and then
are able to run across a variety of
different devices in Tesla and the great
thing about all these test scripts is
it's incredibly easy to go back in and
rerecord them if some reason your UI or
your images change
alright let's switch to the demo Marvin
please alright so this is a test this is
the integrated development environment
and I have mecha hamster which is the
game I mentioned earlier running locally
on this device here
I probably shouldn't pick it up so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you how
easy it is to build up a script so I can
for instance say I want to touch this
area of the screen and we're gonna use
air test here and it will allow attempt
to recognize that image and click on it
and then I can say well I want to wait
for some something to appear so I'll
select another part here so as you can
see I'm building up a script by
interacting with my game that I can then
test across this device running locally
or under this strangely named menu item
called overseas devices I can build this
into an instrumentation test that I can
then run across all those devices that I
want to run them on inside of test lab
which gives you the ability to write
these test scripts and then test them on
the devices your users how alright
Marvin if we can switch back to the
slides
and if you want to learn more I'll step
out the way just in case these are some
some links there's the github project on
which a where a tes resides and that's
the link for where you can download the
IDE I'll let you take a photo all right
so the third option that I'm going to
present today it's called game loops we
introduced game loops probably a year
and a half or so ago game loops provide
a way for you to define one or more
critical user journeys through your game
so you could for instance focus and have
a critical user journey a game loop for
every level in your game or you could
focus on every character in your game
and write a game look for that you can
have any number of these game loops and
built into your game so mecha hamster
which you can see behind me is an
open-source game that you can find on
github which we built to test out many
if not all of the features of firebase
so it has real time database it has all
support it has lots of different uses
lots of the different of the different
tools within firebase but it also has a
game loop built into it all right so I'm
gonna quickly demo how we built this
game loop mob and if we can switch again
to the to the demo so I may not have
mentioned this but mecha hamster itself
is a unity game which means we built it
within unity and I'm gonna talk a little
bit about
how we did that so I'm gonna put up some
code here all right so the first most
important thing around about game loops
is that they need to be declared they
need to be declared in this case in the
Android manifest and you can see a
number of lines here it's important to
highlight so you need this part here
basically talking about setting up the
metadata for the for the test loop you
need for every test loop you need an
intent filter that declares the test
loop and that's down there
so now you've set up and declared these
within your Android manifest the way we
built game loops in mecha hamster and
this is not the only way you could build
game loops but it is the gateway we
built it with in mecha hamster it's
particularly easy to set up within unity
is we have a special mode of the game
that records all of the user
interactions or the events with the game
into a file so this game play recording
enabled equals false when we set that to
true mecha answer will start recording
events into a file we can then take
those events and load them in as an
asset within the game and I'll show that
a little bit here so and then when the
game starts up and it's asked this is
actually the game play recorder plus
that is record that basically records
the events and puts them into a file see
realises them out when the game starts
up you can test whether you're running
in a game loop and then load those
assets and simply replay these events
now as I say that's not the only way you
can build a game loop you could build
out a code if you wished just simply
calling function after a function but
this is a pretty easy way to do that all
right Marvin if we can switch back
please to the slides
all right and if you want to know more
about game loops and how you might build
game loops there's a rather long link
all right so I've presented three
separate automated testing mechanisms so
let's talk a little bit about how you
might use each of these different
testing or how and when you might use
each of these different testing
mechanisms so firstly talked about Robo
so Robo is really good for testing the
preamble to the game so it follows
through the menu items logging in
registering all that kind of stuff it's
also really good if you don't have any
tests yet so maybe you're starting off
with a with an initial version of your
game you haven't written any tests you
just want to test it first internal
version that you want to play with what
we see application developers doing with
test lab is using Robo it's kind of a
last-ditch smoke test signal before you
push to production so that you can make
sure by looking at the test results
looking for crashes not responding
whatever looking at the screenshots the
video make sure that you've not done
anything stupid ear test what I
presented second great for testing
specific critical user journeys so I'm
sorry good for the UI navigation
apologies but it allows you to test
basic gameplay allowing you to interact
with the game game loops are really good
for testing
the critical user journeys through your
game
and because it's the same critical user
journey each time it's really good for
caching performance regressions so you
can test you can show that your
performance is not degraded in between
releases and you can look back over to
previous releases and see how long did
this critical user journey take to run
previously and lastly of course we're
not trying to take over all the manual
testing at least not yet
manual testing is still really useful
for complex interactions such as
multiplayer or indeed some of the late
level testing so as I always like to say
now with all of those tests that you've
written you all you need to do is upload
them into a continuous integration
system and every time you make a change
you can be much more confident we talked
about a safety net here you can be much
more confident that you did not break
the game in some obscure way which means
that your developers are happy they have
that safety net they know that for the
most part every day change they commit
they can tell if it's gonna break the
game in some fundamental way so they're
happy your users are happy because
they're not seeing the kind of issues
that you're catching with all of these
tests which is of course ultimately what
we want
so in summary obviously I hope you take
advantage of the testing tools that I
presented today it's like a given these
tools allow you to test with test lab
across a variety of different devices
the sort of devices that your users are
using today but I also want to talk a
little bit about the future because as
we've heard from so many of you what you
really need is for us to be able to test
your game as your best manual tester can
now it's a hard but exciting destination
to reach and we hope to see you there
in the meantime wish you luck building
the best game ever
[Music]